acht Monate Krieg in der Ukraine und wir
wollen anfangen mit relativ
einzigartigen Aufnahmen von der
besetzten Krim im Süden des Landes wir
sehen hier eine ja eine Egoperspektive
einer Drohne und zwar einer Drohne der
Ukraine die nicht wie sonst die anderen
Drohnen immer fliegen und ihre Ziele
angreifen sondern wir sehen eine
schwimmende Drohne die hier beschossen
wird von einem Hubschrauber aus der Luft
die sehen das vielleicht noch mal ganz
am Anfang wenn wir sehen was ich hier
durch Luft bewegt nämlich hier oben ein
russischer Hubschrauber der die Drohne
erst später hat auf sie schießt aber sie
nicht trifft und diese Drohne wurde
eingesetzt am Samstag um russische
Kriegsschiffe zu jagen und auch
anzugreifen und Russland hat auch
bestätigt dass zwei seiner Kriegsschiffe
bei diesen Angriffen beschädigt wurden
wir sehen also da vorne ihr ein
Kriegsschiff auf dem sich die Drohne
nähert und wir sehen immerhin immer
wieder diese Angriffe aus Hubschraubern
die auch von Touristen vom Strand
gefilmt wurden und aber zu nichts
geführt haben wir sehen am Ende sogar
wie hier auf der rechten Seite eine
Bombe einschlägt die also auch da sehen
wir sie die auch auf die Drohne
geschmissen wurde aber hier Ziel
verfehlt und das sind Aufnahmen aus der
Nacht von entweder der gleichen oder in
einer anderen Drohne und wir sehen hier
ein riesiges russisches Kriegsschiff und
zwar die Admiral macarov eine Fregatte
die nach dem Versenken der Moskwa das
letzte russische Flaggschiff im
Schwarzen Meer eben zum neuen
Flaggschiff gemacht wurde offenbar wurde
diese drohe dieses Kriegsschiff letzte
Nacht angegriffen von eben genau dieser
Drohne dieser schwimm-drohne und wir
sehen wie sie immer näher kommt diesen
Kriegsschiff sich in immer weiter nähert
wir sehen auch wie auf die Drohne
geschossen wird aber sie am Ende ganz in
der Nähe dieses Kriegsschiffs offenbar
ja das ist nicht ganz klar entweder
einschlägt oder etwas absetzt
beispielsweise eine Mine oder das auch
nur rammt und wie sieht diese Drohne
wirklich aus das können wir auch zeigen
und zwar aufgrund dieser Aufnahme diese
schwimm-drohne ist in Sebastopol vor
einigen Monaten angeschwemmt worden sie
hat offenbar nicht funktioniert ganz
anders als als letzte Nacht und wir
sehen hier oben die Kamera also mit der
gerade die Aufnahmen gemacht wurden die
wir gerade gesehen haben wir sehen hier
hinten kleinen Teil des Antriebes und
wir sehen hier vorne ganz interessant so
eine Art Kontakte die also unter
Umständen dafür sorgen dass die Drohne
eben erfährt wann sie ihr Ziel erreicht
haben hat wann sie das Schiff erreicht
hat und dann gegebenenfalls auch
explodiert das ist nicht ganz klar wir
sehen nur dass das drohnenvideo endet
direkt vor dem russischen Kriegsschiff
und die Russen geben zu wie gesagt dass
die Admiral macarov und ein weiteres
Minensuchboot am Samstag beschädigt
wurden bei ukrainischen Angriffen wir
wollen uns aber auch vom Süden des
Landes hier unten dass das ganze
passiert ins hiervastopol Jetzt uns
Videos angucken aus dem Osten und aus
der Region nach hersong hier im Süden wo
weiterhin gekämpft wird und wo sehen das
hier ganz gut die Ukraine immer mehr auf
hochpräzisionswaffen setzt denn was wir
hier sehen ist ein russischer Panzer der
sich dort versteckt das erstes Video ist
aus dem Osten des Landes und wir sehen
wie außenrum ja noch nicht geschossen
wurde also wie keine weitere Einschläge
zu sehen sind und wir lassen das Video
jetzt mal laufen und sehen das wirklich
erste Einschlag direkt den Panzer trifft
das heißt wir können davon ausgehen dass
hier Munition benutzt wurde mit
westlicher 155 mm Artillerie und wir
sehen gleich ein weiterer Explosion
genau auf dem Panzer Munition benutzt
wurde die also auf den Meter genau ihr
Ziel trifft das heißt die ukrainerfahrer
lassen sich offenbar immer mehr auf
diese diese Art von Munition man nennt
sie auch Exkalibur die also noch über
dem Ziel sich das genau anguckt die
Munition selber und dann eben genau hier
in den in den Rand des Panzers
einschlägt und ihn zerstört dass das
erste Video was wir was wir dazu sehen
ein zweites Video haben wir hier dieser
Panzer in der Region wie gesagt im Süden
wurde bereits getroffen brennt hier
bereits und es passiert das was wir
schon oft gesehen haben nämlich dass
aufgrund der hier kreisförmig gelagerten
Munition im Turm sich der ganze Turm
abspringt und nach oben fliegt in einer
riesigen Explosion wir sehen das jetzt
mal
gesehen diese Flugzeuge werden jetzt in
größeren Gruppen sogar eingesetzt um
eben den russischen Invasion etwas
entgegen zu bringen